this week we are partnered with
hellofresh and Rocket money more on them
after the
reaction what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation I am joined by Roxy
strier cuz we are going to embark on a
journey we are going to park our car at
the hasbin hotel today we don't know
anything about it other than some basic
facts it was once a pilot on YouTube by
the YouTube channel vivz pop and now it
is a huge Amazon show man the requests
have been coming in and Roxy is always
like I'm the TV girl everyone knows me
as the TV girl I don't know what that
means but I said all right we're going
to do this TV show together we're going
to start with the pilot and make our way
through episodes one through whatever
Roxy what were we going to say you do
know what it means I watched 115 shows
last year and the previous year I watch
more TV than anybody I know that is my
claim to fame does that make me the
greatest TV Watcher of all time quite
possibly and I'm excited for this one
you told me about it since you said it
everybody I've seen has been talking
about it kind of looks like Harley Quinn
the Animated Series to me which I love
excited to see what we're getting into
because we are not hasband yeah I heard
is like a comedy musical I just got the
hasbin thing yeah hasb been we're not
hasbin we're
currents leave a like on this
video also be sure to subscribe and
click that Bell we got a lot of episodes
to go through I'm reserving the energy
and then by the time we get to the final
one it's going to be wow
here thank you to me or prepper for
editing down these highlights I don't
know which one's doing it full length
Reaction watch long we sync with your
own copy of hasman hotels available for
our super sex Rejects at our patreon
page with this being the first episode
and it's not just on YouTube is it's
available for everyone Link in the
description box do the full watch along
it's pilot not the first episode pilot
yeah two different things you told me
okay it's going to be
rough
oh
[Music]
fun oh how cool very
princess Sleeping Beauty
like satanic that's sad what she's
saying
I think I'm going to love
[Music]
this could be me I just knew what a
meaningful song
[Music]
already that's why I feel like it's
Harley Quinn like f you Heaven this
pilot must have come out before Harley
Quinn I think so
[Music]
yeah they say welcome to to Hell welcome
to
[Music]
hell is this actual
hell love how it feels like an old film
there's a classicness to it porn
[Music]
Studios what happened to Franklin must
have died oh my goodness Rosie took him
out waiting to find him little
[Music]
blue it's like if Tim Burton did the
Harley Quinn show
yeah this feels like it's going to be a
lot more harder the hotel is within hell
itself she must work there next cleanse
365 days oh I'm alive I'm alive oh God
thanks for the fun time can you hot
stuff die in hell I can't let it get out
I'm offering my service is to Rando on
the street whatever you
say ouch oh such an
insult some creative to call me you sack
ofly package horse [__] tell the misses
I said hi
schnuck I love how it's drawn like a kid
show and it's got like the whip snap
energy of it too o angel dust let's go
you link hey up your drag show oh God oh
my
God my drugs damn it I know the feeling
those other cowardly Sinners dare not
hinder my territorial takeover a wise
decision the power of my machines are
unmatched no other demon can compare to
the likes of I this is so inventive
giving Dexter's Laboratory gone dark
it's a Cartoon Network element to it
yeah shot them with your ray gun I wish
he'd shoot me with his ray gun this is
where Humpty Dumpty went nothing not a
single beast in this Inferno of
suffering will be able to take back this
Empire from my constrictive
grasp it's like a No Man's Land
everybody will know the name of
serent Pardon who said that what did you
just say to me you Fried Chicken
[Applause]
[Music]
fetuses kaboy you looking for a fight
old man oh hell yeah you want to go
Missy well I'm happy to
Oly good afternoon I'm Katie killjoy he
got an actual smoke mask turf war is
Raging on the West Side between notable
Kingpin serenus and self-proclaimed
spunky Powerhouse Cherry Bomb I'm trying
to keep up with all the words here it's
really hard demons all over hell are
already duking it out to gain new
territory those two seem to really be
going at it nice they're fighting tooth
and nail for that hot spot and I'd sure
like to nail her
Hotpot olyp jackass Tom or should I say
no coming up
next the daughter of Hell's own head
honcho who's here to discuss her brand
new passion now she's like little Nikki
let's do this just look at me and I'll
mouth it to you come on vaggie I know
what to say her name is vaggy oh what if
I sing a song about it you knew I was
going to say that because I know you but
please don't sing this is serious she's
got like an angel heart better at
expressing myself in my goals through
song yeah what did they do to get to
hell they seem like I mean she's the
princess of hell though she seems great
the highlighted bits are the best part
uh it's all highlighted is this a
drawing yes that's the happy ending see
I don't think it's that simple just
please follow the talking points we went
over and do not thinging you know she's
GNA she's the only one who's actually
born here deserve to be here I'm Charlie
Katie
killjoy I'd say it's a pleasure to meet
you but that would be a lie you can put
that away I don't touch the
Gaze how's that working out for you look
my time is money so I'll keep this sh I
think this would be a sick Halloween
costume you're here because Jeffrey
couldn't make it for his cannibal
cooking segment oh cool dumb I'm too
rich and too influential to give a
flying about what some tux wearing demon
princess wants to advertise D there a
hard AR don't get cute with me honey or
I will [__] dare you it's Charlie
whatever tell us about this new passion
project you've been insistently
pestering our news station
about
as most of you know I was born here in
hell and growing up I always tried to
see the good in everything around me I
knew it Greg I mean she's a princess it
makes sense yeah it breaks my heart to
see my people being slaughtered every
year no one is even given a chance I
can't stand idly by while the place I
live is subjected to such violence they
had a chance is she pacifistic isn't
there a more humane way to hinder
overpopulation perhaps we can create in
an alternative way to change Souls
through
Redemption so that's what this project
aims to achieve you're giving people in
hell hope a hotel that rehabilitates
Sinners and sends them to
Heaven that is just so anti-hel I can
see that going over terribly especially
when people have fun in Hell people like
to succumb to the debauchery she's nuts
I figure it would serve a purpose a
place to work towards return I sing a
song babe can't go
worse stupid [__] oh no every single
one of you has something good deep down
inside maybe I'm not getting through to
you Lucifer was an angel oh no oh no oh
no I have a
[Music]
dream about a wonderful fantastic new
hotel
happyer to a specific
client
inside of every demon is a rainow every
is shiny
smile every creepy
hatching Happ
[Music]
cup around and then it's like Sweeny
Todd Vibes yeah
interesting there's a maob humor to it's
[Music]
goth you
losers prescrition Dr AB
[Music]
I feel like she's going to go out a
really dark path
SC Kiss andon CS you want to be in
[Music]
heaven great kind of do you know who
this actress is no idea
it's giving like anak Kendrick
Vibes there's so much Variety in the
color scheme and like the different
animation Styles I keep implementing
throughout look how gorgeous that
is I like these little hints of the
darkness in her that was [__]
oh guys I thought there was a 1% chance
said like her I know right think a
single denisen of hell would give two
shits about becoming a better person
just takes one you want people to be
good just because what does it matter
you're there forever give it a shot we
have a patron already on the other end
of that what's it matter you're there
forever why try just someone named Angel
dustar you what
Tom in any case just not even an
accomplishment I'm sure you can get that
hooker to do anything with enough booger
sugar and lose oh wo been behaved clean
and out of trouble for 2 weeks now
breaking news oh no we are receiving
word that a new player has entered the
ongoing Turf War let's go to the live
feed it's going to be angel dust oh [__]
oh [__] indeed it looks like the one who
just joined the battle is none other
than porn actor angel dust God damn it
you must feel really stupid right
now it's weird it's so mature but it
it's also feels so nostalgic in the way
it's done how does it feel to be such a
total
failure yeah well how does it feel that
I got your pen huh [__] whoa
oops hey thanks for the backup Auntie
you kid no I staying at this crappy
Hotel on the other side of town some
broads are letting me stay rentree if I
play
nice conning the system just some broads
problematic like a Tommy Gun not mine
these crazy [__] are no fun been
clean for two Wings pot
shop oh harder daddy
[Music]
son what a moment have no class in war
the side remembered is the side with the
most style like how he's an actual
serpent is your hat like alive or
something would that make your hat the
top and you the bottom
ooh I wonder if there's like a human
like do the humans evolv into this are
there rules or on Earth did they look
like this or wherever they are I've been
making these sex jokes the whole time
and it's obvious you ain't catching on I
mean it's just sad how inventive with
the anatomy it's making me wonder what
is down there you know you're my
favorite guy to party with you know it
you ready to finish this that's what Mel
Gibson calls that of
cop oh excellent
stuff I want to see your dad but why is
this girl good she's her best friend
yeah but she she's in hell and she's
good seems that right eh you win some
you lose a few
hundred it wasn't that bad
anyway it was awful what kind of
reputation would I have if people found
out I was trying to go clean throws out
my entire Persona your credibility what
about the hotels your little stunt made
us look like aing joke jez jokes are
funny I made you look uh sad and
pathetic super literal don't get your
taco in a Twist baby was that you trying
to be sexist or racist a little bit of
both I'm going to kill him too late but
wait would that make me Double Dead
where exactly do I go to double hell
that's what you wanted to know who cares
if some got hurt most of them are ugly
freaks look around we got a bunch ofing
harlequinn babies down here you're want
to talk hey this body is
Flawless btic man there is no way anyone
is going to want to stay at the hotel
all thanks to you and your you're
selfish [__] does that mean I don't
have a free room
anymore we don't know if things are over
yet try to relax vaggie it'll be okay
what a name does it mean what I think it
means vaggie is that her name have you
heard that name before no but what is
what do you think it means sounds like
vagina it kind of does sound like that
but I don't really know it's like that
combined with saggy so yeah like a
saggy probably a good idea to get some
actual food in this place you know to
feed all the waywood souls you got in
here she's the princess but she's
treated with like zero respect you don't
need to be respectful in Hell she's not
the queen hey mom um I know I keep
calling and you must be busy really busy
she's so sweet I know I don't know if
I'm going to make a difference cool
color change I could really use some
advice mom she's blue I know it's sad I
think Dad was right about me a I'll stop
talking before this gets long she's the
only one who's so human here bye yeah
cuz she's not supposed to be here
Lucifer was an angel if it is the devil
that they're doing says
Lilith yeah so I think it's like a
combination of a bunch of Ls yeah did
you watch the show Lucifer no oh it was
so
good
what's wrong with this guy hey bgie she
wasn't expecting may I speak now you may
Alis pleasure to be meeting you
sweetheart quite a pleasure it's like
old time radio voice what a performance
why I haven't been that entertained
since the stock market crash of
1929 so many orphans stop right
there I'm not going to let you hurt
anyone here you pompous cheesy talk show
[__] Lord if I wanted to hurt anyone
here I would have done so
already cool I'm here because I want to
help say what now now he's got an
alterior motive this hotel I want to
help you run it
but
why sh absolute bottom that's like an
anime character were Montaine lacking
Focus aimless whenever we cut to this
perspective shot of him it's sideways I
love this guy he's such a trickster the
world is a stage and a stage is a world
of
entertainment so does this mean that you
think it's possible to rehabilitate no
you're getting tricked of course not
that's wacky nonsense Redemption oh the
non-existent humanity no no no no what a
dichotomy the chance given was the life
they live before the punishment is this
I want to watch the scum of the world
struggle to climb up the hill of
betterment only to repeatedly trip and
Tumble down to the fiery
Anarchy
right yes indeed I see big things coming
your way a lot of room for character
arcs yeah wait you've never heard of him
before you've been here longer than me
audience Cipher let's go decades ago
Alistair manifested in hell seemingly
overnight whoa overlords who had been
dominant for centuries that kind of raw
power had never been harnessed by a
mortal Soul before very Nightmare Before
Christmas broadcast his Carnage all
throughout hell just so everyone could
witness his ability how satanic radio
demon as lazy as that is many have
speculated what unimaginable Force
enabled him to rival our world's most
ancient and destructive evils this an
entity that was birthed here violent
monster of chaos the likes of which we
can't risk getting involved with unless
we want to end up
erased you're done I mean he sounds like
he looks like a strawberry
pimp do you trust any man any men
men Charlie listen to me he's a
dealmaker pure evil he can't be redeemed
and is most likely looking for a way to
destroy everything like how the ex is
over her hair and I her hair has been
over her eye for half the shots it's
interesting but the whole point of this
is to give people a chance to have faith
things will be better how can I turn
someone away I can't it goes against
everything I'm trying to do I just love
all the abnormalities to the human
design structure everything just feels
out of place so now you're sketchy as
and you clearly see what I'm trying to
do here as a
joke on the condition that there be no
trickster Voodoo strings attached so
it's a deal
then oh are
wicked I uh hereby order that you help
with this hotel for as long as you
desire sound fair H fair enough cool
beans it's enough for him to make
trouble not cool beans my my DEA you
know you're never fully dressed without
one what do that mean you're never fully
dressed without a smile and what can you
do my eminite fellow I can suck you h
no great kiting there's so much
precision and calculation
here like everything feels so
purposefully
constructed oh my God
little
pet oh wow Nifty hi I'm Nifty it's nice
to meet you it's been a while since I
made new friends why are you all women
have any men here I'm sorry if that's
rude oh
man oh my gosh this is awful nope nope
nope no no wow there's a lot of to deal
with that freedom and weep Boys
[Music]
full tell you're turning this to a full
attraction right now my friend I am
doing some charity work so I took it
upon myself to volunteer your services I
hope that's okay are you [__] me h
no I don't think
so be some kind of biging Riot just to
pull me out of nowhere I'm some kind of
clown maybe I ain't doing noing charity
job well I figured you would be the
perfect face to man the front desk of
this perfect voices I can make this more
welcoming if you
wish cheap boo is always welcoming but
then it would be a plastic bottle not
glass hey go yourself only if you watch
me oh my gosh welcome to the Happy Hotel
guy such a deviant I lost the ability to
love years ago you'll find
it you have a dream you wish to tell oh
my God laughable but hey kid what the
hell
Charming demon Bell now let's give these
burning fools a place to dwell take it
boys wow what're great neon inside of
every demon is a lost cause D they this
on YouTube this is insanity the most
expensive YouTube pilot ever
like
simpery this channel just did that I
can't believe that and the voices are
amazing I'm down at this has been home
well well well this is jarring editing
do I know
you oh yes you do and this time I have
the element of
surprise I'm so evil I'm so
evil yes Greg all evil people say
they're evil you didn't
[Applause]
know
wow it's like a poison ivy
thing I mean the whole thing is kind of
like an amalgamation of a bunch of
horror things all in one which weirdly
creates a unique blend well I'm starved
who wants some jumalia wonderful recipe
for jumalia in fact it nearly killed her
ha you could say the kick was right out
of hell oh I'm on a roll the game is
set
nowed way to go Vivian yeah wow that was
wild I did get a heads up that they
changed some of the voice actors maybe I
don't know if they Chang all I thought
that was unbelievably impressive I for I
had to remind myself that this was just
a a a YouTube thing at first I could see
why it got picked up from just the first
episode here going there you got a show
established perfectly they did a really
good job with their archetypes the
trickster comes in right when he does
the main character is like the hero not
an anti-hero I guess she's just the hero
and the leader yeah we've got her best
friend now we've got like the do
debaucherous gambling type yeah that was
really smart now it takes a good what if
concept with your main character to go
what if you're princess of hell had an
Angel Heart post credit
scene now will you shoot me with your
ray
gun yep it's rewi that let's see what
that said what did it say animation is
basically not so much a technical
Implement as like expression of spirit
behind it to see that the spirit goes
into your shooting must be your
overriding ambition honestly that that
part's a little wordy for me it's saying
it's more about like the the expression
than the technical aspect yeah those are
the words that are there and uh you
picked up on it you did it yourself look
at you you're an A+ student right there
oh Greg BL
Rain r ring reneer I don't know I
stopped trying to pronounce it because I
didn't want to do anything
bad I put a little bit of an e emphasis
on where the second I
is I just where I heard my mouth was
going thank you to America's number one
meal kid hellofresh for partnering with
us it's always great to partner with
people whose Services you actually use
because as someone like me who is always
juggling a pack schedule between filming
and editing finding time for healthy
eating can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a GameChanger for my
life with hellofresh I get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and delicious
recipes delivered right to my doorsteps
so I have to step outside it's
revolutionized my home cooking
experience making it not just easy but
super enjoyable and affordable key word
I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flat RADS and their
zucchini pomodora Panet bake both were
mouth watering delicious and fit
perfectly with my pescatarian lifestyle
pescatarian fancy and asking my friends
who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a
meat eater again people I know I've
really recommended their lemon parsley
chicken palard I think is how you
pronounce it and the fuo chicken faito
tacos regardless hellofresh menu has
something for everyone but of course
it's not just about the food it's about
saving time to not having a wait in line
at a grocery store even self checkouts
on fast enough these days the
convenience of having everything
delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her
quick and easy meals like 15-minute
recipes spending less time in the
kitchen and more time doing what I love
which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to
support the channel and also support you
know having a new lifestyle healthy
affordable lifestyle in the year 2024 go
to hellofresh.com reex free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for life
you heard that right one breakfast item
per box while the subscription is active
free breakfast for life for
hellofresh.com reject free use promo
code rejects free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy
and let's keep enjoying those movies and
shows all right reject Nation let's get
real for a moment running this channel
is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for
the channel and my personal life can be
overwhelming that's where rocket money
has been a financial Lifesaver for me
even before I ever partnered up with
them like I said I've been very
fortunate to be working with Brands
whose products I already use so it's a
win-win for a walk but it can be a
win-win for you too cuzz there's a
reason I use them rocket money is a
personal finance app that simplifies
managing money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and
crafting a budget that fits your
specific lifestyle for someone like me
who can easily lose track of expenses
throughout every single day of the month
it's been eye openening to see where I
was overspending stuff I don't use that
I kept paying for especially apps man I
was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your
spending then customizes notifications
to help you stay within your budget
goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling
your financial progress It's a great
feeling they track your monthly
subscriptions too so many free trials I
signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free Tri was done
making it super easy to cancel the ones
you don't use couple of clicks and
you're putting money back in your pocket
telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you
forgot about because rocket money is a
huge asset in helping to uncover those
and even negotiate some of my bills down
with like 20% so if you're ready to take
control of your finances and there's no
better time than now because it is the
beginning of the year check out rocket
money money and see how much you could
be saving stop wasting money on things
you do not use so to help support the
channel and help support your wallet
visit rocket money.com rejects rocket
money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year with over $500
million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident
they'll do the same for you that's
rocket money.com rejects your bank
account will thank you yeah I thought
that was excellent I I mean the the
animation was of course Sublime because
it's got like this flare of retro
vintage also like futuristic so it's
like throw it's it's it's amalgamation
of like a bunch of different time
periods with goth infused and a bunch of
different types of uh interpretations of
hell all infused into one whil also
being nostalgic like you were saying you
know Tim burden Cartoon Network you know
like I didn't get Cartoon Network
growing up but I watch shows like I'm
familiar with the animation like
Powerpuff Girls and Kimpossible I watch
a lot growing up I'm pretty much
Kimpossible today yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah sure and uh yeah you say
like Dexter's Lab but it has that kind
of like energy so you could feel the the
inspiration behind it and as well as the
pass like this this is like an
achievement of a passion project because
I I was convinced I was watching the
first episode from Amazon Prime and I
had to I had a little moment where I got
pulled out like no wait a minute this is
still the you this is the YouTube one
this is I I I did not expect the YouTube
one to feel already like I was watching
a show on a streaming Channel as popular
as like Prime video and yeah we normally
we talk for like so long because mainly
do movie reaction we're going to keep
these short because we got like several
of these to go through but Roxy what did
you what was your first impressions I
feel very similar to you I think that it
makes perfect sense that this almost has
a 100 million views on YouTube I mean
what a great awesome pilot to something
that now I'm really curious to see about
they did a great job setting up their
characters it looked really great it
sounded interesting I like the premise
of this I want to know if it this is the
age-old question can people really
change yeah um and we know nobody can
change if they don't want to but as
somebody who has spent her whole life
changing I know people can change and so
we're about to see what may or may not
be Redemption arcs not everybody can do
it some people can and that concept to
me is at the core of this which is why
I'm so interested in it that's true like
the the actual setup of what the hotel
represents where you got the dueling
aspects I I I'm terrible with names it's
going to take me I probably will
remember everyone's name by the yeah
I'll probably remember everyone's name
by the final episode well there was that
one girl whose name you mentioned mult
uh oh Viagra V vag what's her name vagi
vagi yeah I REM my word there vagi uh
yeah yes say so conf our main girl the
princess yeah princess of hell yeah yeah
vaggie trickster I'm giving them
nicknames yeah just whatever uh one word
uh subjects Lin we could have about them
just to make it easy to distinguish them
but yeah I mean her setup was was
interesting because this I this idea of
redemption in hell is is a fascinating
one to me like I grew up Judaism doesn't
have hell do they no no well Catholicism
does so I grew up with uh Pink Floyd
Pink Floyd has hell I mean hell is a
concept that has exceeded Beyond
Christianity at this point um but I what
I I'm curious if there are like actual
rules established or is it just
something we go with when you're looking
at the anatomy of stuff that I like the
displacement of things like so much of
the hair would go behind the eyeballs or
just like certain designs everything
always felt like it was off and out of
place like Anatomy was was strangely
structured yeah some like some people's
legs one's longer than the others
there's like hearts in the eyes black
eyes like uh the hair length all choppy
and stuff definitely it looked like some
people that had the crap beat out of
them before they got sent to hell and
whatever state maybe you die in is the
state that you exist in here or once you
get here there's wonkiness that takes
place and that's just how you live yeah
was like the snake sent to hell or did
it was it a human that over time it
became the embodiment of of serpent like
being like this is what their evolution
is so I like that concept but the
concept EGS the eggs too yeah were they
were they bad eggs that just went to
hell you know or were they really evil
babies they exact oh yeah we can get
really twisted about it um what did that
baby do what did that Baby D to deserve
to go to hell well the the idea of like
re rehab in Hell there is like the
question of like what is the purpose
like does the re what does the
rehabilitation gain you do you get out
is it a ticket out of hell well they
don't know and that's one of the cool
things that the princess is saying you
know we have a population issue here and
so she's doing this because everybody's
disappearing and people are just getting
wiped out and so I think she's trying to
deal with population control and her
Theory seems to be
if she can rehabilitate people then they
don't have to be in Hell anymore which
you would think would either send them
back to maybe would send them to heaven
but nobody knows that that's what it
will be that's just her Theory it would
be interesting to see if season one
covers that yeah yeah I I do get curious
about how some of the rule if if there
are rules at all you know or is just the
wild west down here in the sense of like
when people die in in this world of hell
are they just do they cease to exist
forever can you actually die already in
hell if you're already dead like what
what happens there well she they've
already mentioned that some people are
gone so clearly either they died or
they're just missing yeah that's what I
mean like what is the definition of
death down here because I actually get
the impression that some people probably
just like roll with it and other people
like ourselves might question it and
because I feel like the show has more on
its mind than what is the the surface
impression I mean it even ends on this
this text which hints at a lot of
subtext that the show is is delving into
because you got a great you got a great
characters very nuanced at the center of
it all and then with all the amount of
lore and detail that they put in through
like every frame whether it's like the
background or the the musical numbers we
talk about that the musical numbers were
amazing because it feels old school but
um everyone still has their own unique
kind of genre or flare to everyone who
got a number that fits perfectly ATT
tuned to their voice like not every song
sounded the same they're all
distinguishable mhm I think it's a great
pilot that's like a that's like a real
pilot I thought this was like just going
to be a Pitch thing but this felt like a
genuine first episode right right it's
not like uh you know uh Always Sunny
which you and I love but always sunny
they shot it on iPhone so for their
pilot they had to re-shoot the entire
pilot this is like a full formed you
could have seen this on Amazon pilot
yeah dude we got to watch the rest mhm
you you you down yeah oh my God yeah all
right well I'm down let's get down with
it Roxy yeah yeah man I think I would
thrive in hell but it's the thing is
like there's got to be a population that
wish that there has to be some people
there who what you can't expect me to
sit next to you after you just told me
that you would thrive in Hell how but
thousand thrive in hell I mean if you're
there you might as well make the most of
it cuz there's got to be you might as
well redeem yourself and try to get to
heaven Greg we're on two different sides
of this coin well there's not a
guarantee about that I mean if you're
already there there's never a guarantee
that you get to heaven but you just try
to be the best person you be this is why
I'm never going to hell and this is why
you are already there I mean but if you
can like steal and kill with no
consequences wouldn't that be fun that's
why we have Grand Theft Auto video games
so you think you can
tell I don't know I feel like there's a
fun from Hell the thing about is
everyone here Blue Sky from Pain wants
to stay at Hell there's got to be some
people who are like why did I come here
I don't deserve to be here you know some
people because at this point that means
everyone has accepted why they're here
there there got be like weak people here
who feel like they can get out of hell
wish you were here see we're on the same
page I'm vibing with you man we're
vibing right now okay well should we
Vibe on over to episode one I'm Gonna
Keep delaying it I feel like I've said
we're going to end this video like so
many times but I feel like let's just
extend this my personal H all right he
won't let me go to episode one let's go
to episode one see you soon reject
Nation